why don't we create an app for women so
that you know basically so that women
could have like this woman only support
network and cut to 3 and a half years
later I'm being taken to Australian
federal court by a man who claims to be
a woman the moment that you say that I
have to think you're a woman and come
into a woman's space you've made it my
business and I'm not going to accept it
but I was like no you want a day in
court okay there's a huge chance that
this case will go to the high court so I
have to raise a million dollars to fight
for the right to say a man is not men
Our Guest today is an Australian founder
of women's only app which has proven
extraordinarily controversial it's
called giggle she's called s Grover s
welcome to trigonometry thank you so
much for having me uh it's been a while
in the making uh so happy to have you on
the show uh before we get into it s tell
everybody a little bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that lead you
to be sitting here talking to us okay so
basically I you know spent a lot of time
at University I did a bachelor and
almost two master M degrees I left just
shy um finishing a master's degree in
philosophy and then I went to Hollywood
of all places where you know Academia is
just so respected but I wanted to write
and um I got into the industry
relatively easily and quickly in
hindsight once I was in the industry
working in it it became a nightmare that
I was just so unprepared for it was
everything that of the me to movement um
became about so I in about I was 20 18 I
came home it was only going to be for a
holiday I was in therapy just trying to
recover from everything that had
happened my therapist said you should
have a strong female support network in
your life and that was just such a
life-changing moment it just resonated
with me so much and my mom and I were
speaking a lot about what I'd been
through and what I was learning in
therapy and it was my mom who said why
don't we create an app for women so that
you know basically so that women could
have like this woman owny support
network in the palm of their hand and
initially it was going to just be a
roommate app but we developed the idea
we were like oh it can be for like
roommates and freelance work and
emotional support just having a voice
and lesbian dating and finding friends
just anything that a woman might need to
do like on a little corner of the
internet um before we launched it trans
activists discovered us um and
infiltrated the App Store and Google
play with onestar reviews called us
transphobic um got blacklisted from
everything I had never heard the word
Turf before I had no idea what was
actually going
on and cut to three and a half years
later I'm being taken to Australian
federal court by a man who claims to be
a woman and the Australian Human Rights
Commission has intervened in the case on
his side and I have to raise the federal
court $500,000 but there's a huge chance
that this case will go to the high court
so I have to raise a million dollars to
fight for the right to say a man is not
a woman that's basically where we are
wow there's obviously a lot to unpack
there Sal so let's just go back to to
the moment where you decide to develop
this app uh it got targeted you
mentioned before being released even how
did that happen so we were on the App
Store and Google Play just doing some
beta testing you know just before we
would had planned to you know launch it
w wide and there was a handful of women
around the world mainly like friends or
friends of friends you knew about it and
we were just you ining out any little
bugs um testing all the features and our
security and everything and basically to
get on the app so it would be female
only we had an onboarding process which
was that you would take a selfie and
that selfie would go through Ai and it
would be that AI would help us determine
if the user was male or female just
based on a selfie because you actually
can tell if someone is male or female
just by looking at them this is how it's
always well there goes our monetized
thanks down the drain no I remember when
we when we first got the idea and we
were thinking like how would this even
be possible to make an online space just
for women and when we found out that
there was this technology that we could
use my thought was oh well that's the
least controversial way to do it because
everyone takes selfies all the time and
you can yeah you can just tell like we
walk down the street every day not even
realizing that we're registering that's
a man that's a woman blah blah blah like
it's just it's so beyond
like just somec conscious second nature
whatever so I was really excited I
didn't know that we had so blindly yet
perfectly walked into this sex versus
gender War where people were saying that
any man could say he was a woman and be
accepted as that I mean we we couldn't
have we couldn't have planned it better
and so I'm not sure exactly how the
trans activists found us but they did in
that testing phase and because we didn't
have all of like the onboarding features
set to how they were going to be for
launch or anything just we were
inundated with thousands upon thousands
of men who created profiles saying kill
turfs and rape turfs and what not so
that's how I was introduced to the term
Turf and they left reviews on the App
Store and Google play like thousands of
of them saying you're transphobic and
whatnot so it was uh the 7th of February
2020 so just straight away I was like I
have to find out what's going on like
this is insanity and I found on Twitter
um that there were women like Helen
Joyce Julie bindle Kathleen
star um Jane CLA Jones Glenna all these
people and then a lot of other women as
well speaking out going you know sort of
the house is on fire and I just and no
uh Kelly Jay is the other one sorry that
I also discovered and I just I just
started researching everything I could
about it and then when JK did her around
when she did her essay that's what sort
of gave me the courage to be like okay I
need to start speaking out about this
because I have a startup that's
foundering and I I don't believe I've
done anything wrong and so how did this
start was it a particular individual who
let other people know on social media
was it part of a storm I mean how did
this begin I have absolutely no idea
where that very first one began I
couldn't tell you but I do know that
like um as we went on like so there
would be me like men every day would try
to get on sometimes like it could be a
really slow day so there might only be
50 but then you'd have a day when it was
like thousands like and like thousands
and hour it was just crazy and they they
take the selfie so you'd see who was
trying to get on and they were just men
um and sometimes they'd be this big
influx and they'd be wearing gamer
headsets and so we'd be like oh this
must be a twitch related thing or
something um but that's the most we
could no sometimes it would be trans
activists on Twitter because I I I find
the tweets like um that Katie Montgomery
individual had done it a few times in
fact when I was in labor with my
daughter we were under attack then and I
eventually had to say like I can't
monitor this anymore I have to go to the
hospital um but yeah so sometimes we
could trace it to sort of some trans
activist online but other times it was
just like who knows where this is coming
from
we're under attack and because there was
one particular individual who was the
the headliner shall we put it uh
charmingly named Roxy
tickle yeah so roxan tickle is the man
who claims to be a woman who is taking
me to federal court so his story with
the up is slightly different in terms of
um not being sort of someone who like
sort of came in during an attack I don't
think I'm not 100% sure but anyway so he
actually did make it on to the app and
I'll explain how that can happen so with
the onboarding software that we had we
had it set to 94% accuracy because
through our testing we found that was
the safest way so no woman would get
rejected but maybe occasionally there
would be a man that would come through
and our
reasoning was it would be better to have
to kick out some men occasionally than
to
not have to have any woman like just be
rejected from the app so rightly or
wrongly that's what we went with so
occasionally there was like a guy that
would' get through we'd be alerted to it
or we'd see it happen we would remove
them um sometimes they would like um
fall through our checking system we'd
find them a few days later we'd kick
them off that's basically what happened
here um I don't remember it at the time
specifically because it was just another
guy I was kicking off but I saw that
there was a guy on there and I was like
oh off you
go and then I think any more of it and
then a few weeks later I got a call and
a text on my phone from him saying like
this is like the first time we became
like a relevant person in my life saying
G Roxy tickle trying to get on the app
um I think he might have said he was
trans then I'm not sure I I didn't keep
the text I just didn't think that this
person was ever going to take me to
court and so I because I had the phone
number I just put it into our sister and
checked and I was like oh that's a man
and I called my dad and I was like
there's this guy trying to get on
Twitter oh Twitter on Google and he's
called and text my phone and my dad said
block him block his like block his
number and don't tell your mother
because my mom lives in like Perpetual
fear that I'm going to get attacked so I
didn't tell her and then two months
later I got a
um I was served with a human rights
complaint from the Australian Human
Rights Commission for Rob sticle for
alleged gender identity discrimination
and at this point I was 15 weeks
pregnant so to put it into perspective
of how long this has been going on for
my daughter is 14 months old and by the
time this is all resolved there's a good
chance she'll be three maybe four so wow
yeah so the case could tickle be giggle
just in if anything couldn't become
moreck giggle tickle V giggle I mean so
there will be people listening into this
going well you know s are you being
unfair why is it so important that your
app is a female only space can you
explain to us why why is it so important
that the app is female only well if the
in terms of just rather instead of just
getting into like the importance of
female only spaces just in terms of this
particular one if the app isn't female
only it's like congratulation I've
invented Twitter like the the point of
difference with it is it's female only
like I mean if I was to let men who
claim to be women on then it's not
female only and yeah I I've just
invented a place that's exactly like any
other place on the internet so you know
yeah there's no point to it um then if
you go deeper with it um why fight back
is because one it's not true it's just
not true like this person is not a woman
and I'm just I'm not going to give in to
that I refuse to believe it and second
like female only spaces women's rights
in general whether it's female only
spaces women's sport and services all
different opportunities that are offered
to women they just they're just too
important and already like hard fought
for to just give in I I I can't do it
I've never really been someone who is
I've never been an activist before in my
life or anything like that but I'm just
like no I I care too much about this but
I I really am my Foundation of it is
it's just not true I cannot believe it
and I just can't I can't let Society
just force us all to believe this does
it surprise you that
Australia has then
essentially on they're on the side
Australia or the law the legal system is
on the side of this person who claims to
be a woman called roxand tickle
my God it shocks me so much I I had I
had no idea I mean I was in America when
the law was changed so in 2013 what
happened we had our first female prime
minister and it's her government that
did this which is just adds so much
insult to injury so as um Julia Gillard
was prime minister and her government
took out the definition of women from
the sex Discrimination
Act and put in gender identity
into it which made the act
completely muddled because now you have
gender in the sex Discrimination Act and
so obviously it's just like this so it's
not specifically that recognizing sex is
outlawed in any way it's that it's which
one is more relevant now no one has
tested it in any massive way yet in
Australia most people have been um
you just intimidated by the law and the
process there's a lot of places that
have just Fallen to it and given in
because you know it is so
daunting but you know I just I couldn't
because I I mean you guys know what it's
like when you have a startup I've
invested money I you know these people
invested in an app for women it was not
an app for men you think they're women
and women it was just an app for women
and I have a responsibility to these
people and just to women in general and
to myself and so I was like yeah I'll
take it all the way to fight it and so
that's what we're doing we're doing a
constitutional challenge um basically to
try and get gender out of the sex
Discrimination Act because it doesn't
work there well S I really want to pick
up on that because it's really a
fascinating conversation that as you
well know is happening around the world
not just in Australia but I'm curious to
and look I know for you it's personal so
it's perhaps insensitive of me to ask
but I do think it's important it's a
question we've discussed with uh various
people I mean Sam Harris when we last
had him on he was saying well look I
think Twitter should be able to
discriminate against anybody if they
don't want this person on the platform
they're free to do so but then I suppose
the question is what if somebody wanted
to create an app for I don't know only
white people or only Gentiles or
whatever you
know cender or something or or I think
it's called forchan mate whatever right
so you know I suppose the question
Francis asked you earlier I think is
important to answer which is why is it
important to have an app that is able to
exclude men yeah I mean apps that like
so Niche social networks that exclude
people is nothing new I mean in 2010 no
one was asking brinda to justify why
they were excluding women we just
accepted it it was an app for gay men um
it's only because of the introduction of
gender ideology that suddenly we have to
justify all of these things because
they've turned Society upside down so
much but Niche apps and and um
and websites in general exist for
everyone I mean in terms of like there
is apps Rel that are religious based
like there are dating apps like J date
and things like that that that aren't
just based on religion and they've never
been asked to justify themselves in the
manner that something just for women is
and it's interesting like when you're
talking to a lot of women like you we
just get it and then when you talking to
men you to go like how do you try and
explain why um a woman an just for woman
would be important no no I get it too S
I just want you to explain it for people
who are yeah
so I mean the internet is different for
everyone and Cesspool for everybody um
it is very much an interesting place for
women like part of the reason how we got
the idea for it is when I moved from
Hollywood to New York before I'd come
home I was looking for a room to rent in
New York and um in that like I you know
I was just using like roommates.com and
all of those things and you know there'd
be these guys going oh do you want you
could rent a room here for free if you
walk around naked or do you want a
boyfriend as well and it was just like
can I just do one thing without this
schol like just something and so it was
just sort of going like okay there's
just we is there just like just a way to
just have a little Refuge where we could
just avoid that if we wanted to like
obviously there's lots of women who are
like oh no don't care I can use that but
like I'll use anything I don't this
stuff doesn't bother me and that's fine
but then there are women who just like
no I'd like to just spend some time with
women basically and and talk and just
connect and talk to women all around the
world so yeah I mean I I understand the
need to um to justify and obviously like
I mean I'm going to have to in court but
it it is it is a weird situation where
you're like you know there is an out
there right now it's called only fans it
encourages like 18year old girls to get
on there and take naked photos of
themselves for like a depressingly small
amount of money for most of them and
again no one is asking anyone to justify
this but the moment it's like something
for women it's like why why would you
want that and I think the answer is
because we do because we want it I I
don't know if you have to go you should
have to go much further than that in
sort of a just in a social
situation I mean look I agree agree with
you but what does it say as to the wider
Society to the way that we perceive
women to the way that women
are let's say I mean judged in one way
or another the fact that you want to set
up an app which is only for women and
for the vast majority of people they go
oh yeah okay I get it that makes sense
but to a small percentage of people that
is deemed to be offensive I mean what
does that say well yeah I mean because
most men like most men are lovely we
wouldn't be functioning as a society if
most men weren't lovely and so most men
don't even go near the thing like they
just be like oh that exist who cares the
moment a guy is trying to get onto it
you're like the chances of you being a
lovely guy a slim to
none but at the same time like it's like
say she use the example that I'm going
through like Roan tikle can't go on the
app for the exact same reason that my
dad can't use it like the the man that I
trust more than any man in the world so
I'm not making necessarily a personal
judgment on like the applicant in the
case it's just they're just male okay
just for no other reason like it's just
you're just a
guy we'll be back with our guest in a
minute but first we want to take a
moment to talk about our partners give
send go if you need to raise funds
online but don't want to hand over your
money to faces big Tech corporations
then give and go is a place to do it giv
and go is a leading crowdfunding website
where thousands of people in the US the
UK Australia and Canada raise funds for
anything from business ventures and
medical expenses to personal needs
churches and funeral costs on giv and go
you can raise money for whatever you
need we've met the people at giv and go
and we can tell you that they're
absolutely aligned with us here at
trigonometry on our approach to free
speech they've proved time and again
they won't gave to the Mob they don't
just talk the talk they walk the walk
unlike other big tech companies and
that's why we are proud to partner with
them they like us believe that with
openness and honesty we create more
understanding and ultimately more
Harmony in the world give send go is
absolutely free to use with other
crowdfunding sites you'll pay between 5
and 10% of the money you raise GI and go
charges no money at all to use their
platform they believe you should be able
to keep all the money that you raise
starting a campaign on give send go is
easy and intuitive go to give send
go.com today that's give send go.com to
start raising money for whatever is
important to you and now back to the
interview s do you think a lot of this
is happening because we've sort of tried
to pretend for a while that there is no
difference between men and women and
people have sort of been bied this idea
but actually there is quite a big
difference and I understand by the way
the intention of the people who wanted
to erase those differenes they wanted to
protect you know they wanted to empower
women they wanted women to get into
places where power was held etc etc but
we somehow ended up in a place where
maybe that that idea got taken to its
logical conclusion and now we're here
yeah I wrestle with this a lot because
like I you know obviously like say
feminism would be the the the ideology
or like the the belief system or
whatever that that would be talking
about here because that's what would is
the one that did it and you know there
there's nothing that's above criticism
so I think that it's always important to
just go like oh hang on did they do
something wrong or did they go too far
um you know mean I go like even if there
were just some feminists or or women who
called themselves self-identified as
feminists that they're actually not they
sort of like lost their way a little bit
and sort of overthought something that
didn't even need to be thought about I
just go like yeah but still there was
there was no feminist Theory or want in
society that was ever like implemented
without like a massive fight like huge
huge fights I mean women to get the
right to vote was decades and very
traumatic whereas this well in terms of
how it was just implemented in to
society and institutional capture and
then into
laws in stealth for most of the time I
just don't think that Society went this
one feminist idea we're going to really
grab and just Implement with no argument
and go with it and no debate no
questions I just the it doesn't um it it
doesn't make sense to me so while like
there might have been some academics who
are sort of talking
nonsense I don't know if that's really
what caused this I do think I'm sort of
in agreement with like Helen Joyce on
this that it was like the autophiles the
sort of the sexual
fetishists especially the really
powerful ones with like she calls it
like the nuclear reactor in it and just
that that drive and their money and
power was potentially the thing to get
us to where we are now more than
anything else in terms of where we are
in legal capture I think because they
want more than anything else to be able
to go into female only
spaces and what is their argument s
because I'm sure that isn't it what is
their argument as to why they should be
allowed to access your app is it that
you're being transphobic is it that uh
you're not uh affirming their Identity
or is there something else well if they
claim to be women they are women
according to the the current definition
right so you're you're discriminating as
women
well yeah what's
really you would think then if they
actually thought of this individual as a
woman or any man who claims to be Woman
as a woman then wouldn't it be sex
discrimination but they're like no this
is gender identity discrimination and
it's like well the fact that you're not
even calling it sex discrimination
actually does prove to a point that you
don't think this person is a woman
either you're just going in with an
ideology that's been created um they so
the the Australian Human Rights
Commission has intervened in the case as
Amicus Cur which means Friend of the
Court um and they're definitely not my
friend in the court um they have
intervened and said yes this man is a
woman um the submission that they came
out a few weeks
ago I'm I can't even articulate it it is
the most batet insane 26 Pages I've ever
read in my entire life it's like you're
reading it going like this is like a
draft for 1984 that Orwell went no no
one will believe this I've gone too far
like let's strip it back they literally
say that um biological this is the sex
discrimination commissioner saying this
sex is not binary but it can also be
changed they at one point they were
saying that um a trans woman's desire to
be pregnant would mean that they are a
woman you know what on Earth are you
talking about like we're talking about a
man here and
so you just like they don't really have
any arguments Beyond we say he's a woman
so therefore he's a woman and and sex
can be changed so there you go and
you're like but where's your evidence
that's one of the craziest things in the
whole process and I think some other
people who have had to go through legal
processes with with this with gender
ideology specifically would feel the
same you're in this position where
you've got a find all of this evidence
and and you know argue your case and
make sure you can back it up with facts
but at no point is anyone going should
we get evidence that he's a
woman and I'm like because that's stops
there for me like if you're just being
able to assert he's a woman like that's
just not how the legal process works in
any other area from my understanding was
always been evidencebased
and you know you just you go like you
one of the things in um in the human
right
submission submission and description of
the law they're saying you know it's a
gender identity and it's gendered
behavior and you're like well you know
if we're talking about lived experience
or anything here this gendered behavior
is exactly how I would expect a man to
behave like where does my lived
experience come into it like during this
process I was pregnant I had a 20 weeks
scan I found out that I was having a
girl does that mean nothing like just no
it just means you're transphobic but so
but I want to ask you do you think that
the this is all about the invention of
this idea of gender
identity and and everything else
Cascades down from that we've had this
conversation with many people on the
show as you know I am very I remain
highly unconvinced that the creation of
the concept of gender was a useful a
good thing um and it seems to me like
once you say well there is sex and then
there is gender and you can change your
gender this inevitably follows because
the concept of gender is sort of how you
behave makes what you are and then well
then people can pretend to be whatever
they want because they can wear a dress
and then suddenly they are a woman yeah
I mean there is an argument to be made
that they the gender does not need to be
in the law at all and it would actually
be better for society if it wasn't
because
first of all you know making um an
identity es especially sort of you know
just this um self- declared identity the
responsibility of the law is in
incredibly difficult and messy but even
just like the protection of sex which
everybody has and it's you know easy to
acknowledge and establish and everything
actually does all of the work in the law
so like if you are a man who wants to
wear women's clothes or whatever which
like I am very like Live and Let Live
even even if I don't like the reason why
he wants to wear women's clothes like
whether is autophilia or something still
I'm like in a free Society I can't stop
you like go and wear women's clothes the
law doesn't have to be
involved in any specific way because if
say in in a employment situation You'
think that if he wanted to wear women's
clothes and he was told he was not
allowed it would be on the basis of his
sex that he wasn't allowed because
they'd be going you're a male and so you
can't wear women's clothes but if so
that would be that would be a sex
discrimination you would think so yeah
gender doesn't need to be there the
state should stay out of people's brains
like this it doesn't need to happen it
should just be there to make sure
Society is functioning but gender has
made it that nothing is functioning like
everything is falling apart everything's
getting distracted because of this like
the stupidest issue of all time yeah and
it's look and let's be brutally honest
about this uh
Australia don't have a good record for
for the last couple of years for staying
out of people's lives we saw that during
covid you went to use a technical term
absolutely batshit as a result of that
yeah it's it's interesting it's one of
those situations where when like when
you're living here you know you don't
you don't feel it like slowly creeping
in it's just very sudden you sort of
wake up one day and you go oh it's go
it's been happening for years
um yeah um it's unusual because
Australians are pretty easygoing people
also pretty straightforward and like no
kind of people so but there
it's definitely definitely like there is
that I mean it's like in the UK it's
like in the US and Canada we're so
divided right now of basically the
people have bought into all of this crap
and seem to apparently love being told
what to think and then you've got all
the other people who were like no i'
prefer to think on my own things so yeah
I that's part of how I missed it like
that it was even all happening with the
gender stuff was I was focusing
on I was sort of still you know like me
true bubble also in my online like
algorithms I was very much in like I
hate Trump Twitter bubble I didn't tweet
but I would read everything so so I
completely missed that this was going on
and then Co happened and I was starting
to go oh oh that's a bit weird and then
yeah we all woke up to find out that oh
hey you don't have that many rights
anymore it was weird to watch certainly
from us and it's not like the UK was
particularly good on on that stuff
either uh and tell us more about how the
legal case has gone and what your
expectations are for the future yeah
so we
basically he so he he' done last year
he' done the Australian human rights
complaint
I could have gone to conciliation with
that and that's where they they try and
resolve it outside of the courts
basically like a mediation type thing
but I'm sorry to interrupt s what does
this guy want he wants to be on the app
he wants
compensation yes and yes and he wants a
written apology and um all men who claim
to women on the app um in in court he's
going for money as well for damages but
in initial human rights complain he
wasn't the conditions for me to go to
conciliation were that I'd have to him
on the app all men claim to be women on
the
app um an apology attend sex and gender
education which could only be
re-education because I am very educated
on this issue like I can teach death
class um so so they want sorry again
sorry to interrupt but I think this is
important not to skip over part of the
things that you will do if you lose this
case you have to go on a re-education
course no no no this is reconciliation
sorry okay so this was in the Human
Rights Commission and then the other
thing was um they wanted me to mod um
moderate all content on the app so that
like men like him would not be offended
because basically there are a lot of
women just turfing out on there and
talking about their rights and because
of course they can they can go and talk
about them without trans activists men
male trans activists getting abused now
a female trans activist would be welcome
to come on to the app um so long as she
was civil and didn't harass and just
ided by the rules like you don't there's
no like thought control or anything no
one has to agree with everything but I
mean they basically stayed away from it
it was only the men who were trying to
get on so I said no to conciliation
because I knew that I was never going to
agree to those terms and then also by
this point I was like third trimester
pregnancy and I didn't the stress of it
I was I'm not putting myself through it
not going to happen and so we said no to
it and knowing that the risk could be
that he'd take it to federal court so
then he had 60 days to file he filed on
the 61st
day the 60th day but just how the days
felt was felt was the 61st then he
withdrew about a month later which we
were like oh basically that's a win like
we've won this and then he refiled again
about five and a half months later like
Christmas time last year so when he
refiled again he was what's classes out
of time like Beyond like the time from
the complaint when he was able to do it
so he had to get granted permission to
for the case to be heard
and by this point I was like we could
have really pushed back on that but I
was like no you want a day in court okay
I'm not going to push back on this like
it it has this we have to resolve this
and if this is the case it's going to
help resolve it I'll take it on like you
know you you don't want to do it but
you're sort of in the position where
you're like okay I'm just going to rise
to the occasion because maybe hurtfully
we can just end this and we can all live
on with our lives and have some
normality back so in the case yeah he's
asking for
um yeah money for damages and like
because how much money so well I'm not
sure because Australian damages work
very specifically so like I don't think
that it's not I don't think it's like
millions and millions of dollars Al it
wouldn't shock me at this point I mean
who knows like but um but it's it's
still just money like it is a thing we
just go like it's just an app it's just
an app and like I I don't but but it's
not though you know that right because
this isn't an app this is about the
principle that's why you that's why
you're fighting it because of the
principle no exactly so it's just yeah
so basically um the other and actually
this just to go back to your point
earlier about um about people being able
to choose who in is who who are on their
platform and who are not and where sort
of is the line with that so for us we
built our own crowdfunding platform
because they had the resources to do it
like the ability to do it and we knew
that we would get kicked off like
GoFundMe or anything like that because
they are all captured by this stuff so
like just we I don't want the stress of
it we'll just cut it out we build our
own we have been so then building our
own we had to put in payment systems
like so that you know you can just put
your card details in or Apple and Google
pay whatever so we've been kicked off to
payment platforms on the basis of
complaints been kicked off stripe and
we've been kicked off Square so the
crowdfunder is actually down at the
moment because we're trying to find a
third we're in the process of fixing
it'll be fixed in the next few days um
thankfully but at the both of the times
that it's happened it's obviously a huge
inconvenience and it's really
frustrating but I've always sat there
and gone well if you don't want us to
use your platform I respect that I don't
love it but I respect it I'm not going
to go and take you to court over it what
I would like is the right to do the same
thing is to choose who is and who is not
on my platform so even during this
process I've like experienced people
having the rights that I would like to
have um
and yeah not hopefully we'll get there
and I think we will like I'm very very
optimistic about it because I just think
I just think truth has to win out
eventually sometimes you have to fight
for it but I think you get there in the
end it's just try yeah yeah I mean I
hope that as well my question is do and
and look maybe you don't know the answer
to this how is he getting his
money um so from my understanding his
legal team is pro bono because you know
I mean you're the big firm it's like oh
this is a big you know civil rights
human rights case you know poor
transgender woman not being allowed to
go on a nap this is a big case so that's
taken care of and then he also got a
$50,000 Grant from um it's called the
pra
fund which um is um like a they they F
give like funding to like legislation
challenges and and things like that so
yeah I mean but in a case like this
where um you know a federal court case
$50,000 is lunch so it's not like an
obscene amount of money that he's been
given but yeah I mean the
financial threat to him is significantly
different than what it is to me like
obviously there is no government funds
that I can go to to others for money
because I'm battling the government and
they're against me so while the case is
obious like tickle B giggle it it is
fundamentally because of the Australian
Human Rights Commission it's giggle
versus the government wow and uh what
happens if you win do they have to do
they have to rethink the law is that why
you're doing this or what happens so
there's a few different ways that it can
go
so we're expecting that it's going to go
to the high court no matter what because
if we were to lose in federal court
obviously we're going to appeal it to
the high court and if they lose
especially the Australian Human Rights
Commission losing the federal court
there's a huge chance that they would
take it to the high court so you're sort
of in this now going like
it's high chance it's going to go to the
high court so the high court is really
where the Constitutional arguments will
come into play from my understanding so
if we were to win on a con
constitutional
basis um and it was to be found that
gender being in the sex Discrimination
Act is unconstitutional I part of the
reason for that is with sedor which like
the UN and sedor and the you know um the
protection of women's rights and all
that I'm going to have a complete brain
fart of what it all stands for but
anyway look it up it's all very
important um you we're a signatory in
that and they you know this is not an
organization that claims that that trans
women a women and our sex Discrimination
Act is based on this so that's what part
of where our constitutional argument
comes in if we win that constitutional
argument in the high court it would mean
that gender is taken out of the sex
Discrimination Act so it would mean that
sex is once again the defining factor of
the sex Discrimination Act which is what
a stupid sentence to have to say but it
would mean that female only spaces were
female again female only Sports and male
only spaces as well because I think that
men deserve privacy and dignity in male
spaces as
well um it would mean that self ID was
off the table it would it would just it
would just end it and so would I they're
not obviously going to go just slink
away and be like oh well we gave it a
shot they would obviously try and come
back and weave it through the law in a
different way but they'd be doing it
where sex had been established as the
important thing and also people knowing
what's going on and watching so it will
change the climate of it definitely it
sounds like a really important case to
me actually s because I think one of the
things that has been happening is
there's a tremendous amount of uh
cowardice actually around this issue uh
and I think everybody's just looking for
somebody to take the first step and so
if Australia was to come to a position
as a result of you winning where you
were forced to rethink the sort of
structural legal underpinning of all of
this I think a lot of other anglosphere
countries might might then be emboldened
to follow suit definitely I mean it's
it's like how like you know in the UK
where you guys are in such a better
position than we are on this particular
issue you know part of the reason is
because women in the UK took it to the
courts and they won um and we just we
didn't have a chance to take it to the
courts before a lot of the stuff was
done because we didn't know about it um
so we are undoing some of the damage so
it is just bigger and a little bit
harder but still completely entirely
possible I mean laws get repealed all
the time it's not out of the ordinary so
yeah it's just it it will be hopefully
the thing that makes other countries
like especially Canada for example if
you think of other commonwealth
countries to make them go oh hang on
maybe maybe there's something in this I
mean just last week a um news
organization in Australia called
news.com.au which is very much against
us um they call me a um a conservative
media figure all the time because
welcome to the
club really they only ever refer to me
as like a media figure or conservative
media figure and I'm like and why am I a
media figure what am I talking about
like they won't give any publicity to
giggle or anything like they won't tell
people what I actually do um but they
just did a poll and found that only 4.2%
of Australians think trans women are
women and like 880 2.5% of Australians
don't want trans men in women's sport
it's like this is like deeply unpopular
in the public it's just the
institutional level like yeah well Matt
Goodwin who is a regular guest of ours
as you know he tweeted something uh
recently which basically shows that
support for self ID and all of this
stuff is just going through the floor as
people get more educated about the
issues and it's not surprising cuz
surprise surprise it's not that
complicated this issue is not that
complicated actually that's what trans
fob but it's they help the the the trans
activists try and spin it and say like
there's an increasing amount of
transphobia in society and it's not it's
just more people realizing that these
gender policies are nonsense right and
starting to fight back against them it's
like if like the trans gender activism
Community had gone look we just are a
demographic of people who you know like
to appear like the opposite sex I think
I think it would have been pretty easy
to get people to be like okay about that
like most people are Let Live and Let
Live don't really care it doesn't bother
me you know get on with it it's because
they said that we have to believe this
lie you know in fear of punishment that
we all fought back like if it was just a
situation like would say Roxy tickle I'm
like if you want to get up every day and
call yourself a woman and wear woman's
clothes and take hor Mones or whatever
that's none of my business I wish you
well the moment that you say that I have
to think you're a woman and come into a
woman's space you've made it my business
and I'm not going to accept
it we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to talk to you
about ag1 if you're a longtime fan you
might know we've been drinking ag1 for
over a year now to stay healthy and
saave off illness in preparation for
whenever our schedule gets really busy
when we use ag1 on our busy America
tours we found that we feel a real
difference to our energy levels and our
ability to focus so my concentration
span has gone from 2 seconds to 12
that's because ag1 is a foundational
nutrition supplement that supports your
body's Universal needs like gut
optimization Stress Management and
immune support since 2010 ag1 has led
the future foundational nutrition
continuously refining their formula to
create a smarter better way to elevate
your Baseline Health even the
triggernometry team here have started
drinking ag1 and they love it our
producer was just telling me about how
how much more energetic he feels that
his stress levels feel more manageable
now and because of this we're hoping
he'll hit his deadlines for the first
time in over 5 years ag1 is the
supplement I trust to support my daily
health and that's why they've been a
trigonometry partner for so long now if
you want to take ownership of your
health it starts with ag1 try ag1 and
get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3
K2 and five free ag1 travel packs with
your first purchase go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com
trigonometry check it out and now back
to the
interview there's more more and more
places in Australia that are fighting
back um the lesbian action group which
is a Melbourne based group they're
trying to get an exemption to be able to
hold a female only lesbian event like
there's any other kind and the
Australian Rights Commission has just
said no to
them um and so therefore wait so
lesbians can't have a female only event
no not in Australia at the moment our
case will fix that but at the moment no
because the reasoning is so bizarre um
basically they're all like you know
we're just against discrimination it's
like well you're not because you're
discriminating against lesbians right
now but you've just made a choice
discriminate against lesbians or
discriminate discriminate against
heterosexual men who like to wear
dresses and you made your choice you
ored against lesbians so they are
fighting back and willing to take it all
the way as well which is fantastic but
yeah I mean that's that's where it is in
society like um uh one of the women in
lesbian action group she phrased it so
well she said that you know she can get
married now but she can't go to a
lesbian event to meet a
spouse so yeah like so it's like we're
not going
forward in society we're going backwards
at a very very fast paced and whatever
happens I mean to be blunt you are going
to end up in the high court because if
uh tickle I mean this is just bizarre
loses in the Constitutional Court he's
going to take it to the high court
because he's not going to accept that i'
would imagine so I don't know if it
would be more um him specifically if it
would be the Australian Human Rights
Commission I would sort of think that
the Australian Human Rights Commission
who would of say you know we're going to
fight to the end on this because I mean
they the Australian Human Rights
Commission from my understanding what
I've read about it they were one of the
ones who lobbied for these these laws so
I mean they are really there sort of
protecting the law that they fought for
that they wrote um and I mean so I
understand like just from that
perspective why they would be there
fighting it for for the law that would
be probably quite a normal process it's
just that they've written a law that is
so
insane that that you know they just
didn't it's like they just didn't think
of oh like what are the ramifications
because it's like any part of gender
ideology like if you think about it for
more than one second like by the time
you get to that second second every part
of it has fallen apart because you
should go like oh hang on male rapists
are going to say their women and go I'm
going to reward them by putting them in
women's prisons all female only spaces
and Sport all of that that's gone but
then also society's freedom of belief
and freedom of of speech is just gone in
an instant like they just didn't think
it through they were just like oh
protect this one group and
no these be protected more than anyone
else well said s listen I'm uh I want to
move on to our local sections because
we've got a ton of questions from our
supporters um but just I just wanted to
say that you know you and I've spoken a
little bit on Twitter and stuff and I'm
really glad we had you on because I
don't think I fully appreciated the
significance of the case you're fighting
and the potential impact actually not
just in Australia but in the world so I
really hope that uh obviously you do win
and I I hope that people support you is
there a way that people can support you
at the moment they well yes so um like
hopefully like by the time this comes
out it will all be up and running
hopefully um in the next few days
basically it should all be back to
normal hopefully but it's gigle
crowdfund.com
um that's our crowdfund and there's all
information about the case and the
Constitutional challenge is all there
and I mean we have $500,000 Australian
dollars to raise at this stage which is
just like so incredibly stressful but
yeah I know that we'll get there and
we've had this the kindness of strangers
from all around the world so far have
been has been just absolutely amazing
and I the only way I can repay it back
is by saying like we'll get your rights
back it will be all cool and then you
can go around calling a man a man and
everything will be fantastic well it's a
good cause um s before we go over to
locals we obviously as you know end with
the same question uh uh in this part of
the interview which is what is a
[Laughter]
woman what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be I
think it does sort of come back to
everything that I've just been saying I
don't think we're talking enough about
the fact that just like the very
Foundation of democracy you know the
freedom of belief freedom of speech
freedom of Association is just at the
alar of a demographic men's feelings
right now and it's if if we can't talk
about that and then we can't fix it and
I'm just not willing to give up you know
just this real thing democracy the most
important thing for these people I'm
just I'm not willing to do it uh you
know what I will say this even though
I'm instantly going to fall into the
feminist trap of # Not all men but I I
it's not men's feelings it's a very
small subset of men a demographic of
men's it's a Dem it's a specific
demographic of men yeah it's very
specific is my point very specific like
whenever I talk about this de like I'll
say oh a demographic of men I'll say
this on Twitter and they'll be like oh
not all men I'm like if you don't fit
into that demographic I'm not talking
about you exactly it is a very
demographic I'm just saying I think
they're actually um a lot of men on your
side uh and I think that's you know one
of the reasons I I think progress is
being made is actually is men and women
coming together and working together
which I think we want I yeah exactly I
think that's amazing and I think you
know men
um men men have spoken up sometimes that
they've been in a position more where
they sort of they're not getting rape
threats and death threats for speaking
up at the same sort of rate that a woman
is I mean there are men around the world
who are losing their jobs and being
punished don't get me wrong and I don't
want to ever minimize that but I think
um you know for a lot of men that they
have seen that it's not even just an
attack on women's rights it is an attack
on our basic freedoms and and if even
from my perspective if that's the only
reason you're coming at this issue I'm
fine with that women's rights will be
won as a
byproduct but so it's like if you if
you're like I don't really care about
women's rights I care about truth great
like we're on the same team there we'll
get there in the end together and
women's rights will be saved amen well
head on over to locals where we continue
the conversation especially with your
questions
do you think the trans phenomenum or is
a w is a woke fad or is it here to
[Music]
stay